great
so we'll go over to you know
reinforcement learning and causal
reinforcement learning as um was briefly
brought up by elias so
very excited to have uri joliet here
from the technium and worry it's all
yours okay thank you very much thanks
for inviting me and i'm really sorry i
couldn't be there hopefully we'll get
back to traveling soon
um
so
let's talk about what motivates this uh
the research i'll talk about today uh so
we're thinking about tasks like
autonomous driving or robotics or maybe
in the future medical treatment which we
like to learn automatically
where there are many actions there are
long-term dependencies and high
dimensional state spaces so kind of
difficult ai tasks
and in such tasks learning online is
crucial and because
we all know the problems with offline
data confounding and all that and for
such complicated and high-stakes tasks
we have to uh do some online learning
and in a sense learning online is
optimal from a causal perspective
elias has a lot of work
on that kind of
problem
but
as we also know learning online is often
expensive
it might
require a lot of
money or people or time to do that it's
a natural question is can massive
offline data help by saving us money or
interactions or mistakes that we could
have avoided if we've learned from
offline data
and specifically what like the scenario
i want you to have in mind for this talk
is that we're learning online but we
have access to large offline data
for example it could be a logs from
driving or human demonstrations of
robotic tasks and so on
and the challenges we will address in
this context
is basically where there's some mismatch
between the offline data and the online
environment for example we might have
confounding you might have partial
observability you might have
distribution shifts all of these
problems which are realistically we will
have to face if we're learning uh in
this uh online situation
uh so i just need to do something okay
um
okay
oh sorry it's still not good
okay
so if you want to learn online with some
offline data there's some very obvious
baseline so just so we're on the same
page
uh first we could just ignore the
offline data we're assuming we can learn
online so we can
set our autonomous card driving or our
robot string
and this is most of bandit and
reinforcement literature is about the
same
the other option is we can just ignore
the online data and just use the offline
data
and that's the realm of policy
reinforcement learning for example
and this is vulnerable for example the
confounding and distribution shifts and
sometimes proxies might help we and
others have some work on that but
generally it's a it's difficult to just
use offline data especially if you have
large action spaces and complex state
spaces
and in this talk we'll talk about how to
merge this offline and offline data in
challenging scenarios and of course
we're not the first to do this there's
other work as cited here and and much
more
okay so i'll talk about two specific
projects
and let's just start with it with the
first
which was presented as a paper in uai
2021
and this is in the realm of bandits and
specifically we're talking about the
linear banded interaction model so i'll
go over this model briefly i assume most
of you have seen this
so we have rounds t
one
starting from one we observe some
context x
uh from some distribution we take an
action which is a function of x out of
an action space a discrete action spaces
of
a actions we get some noisy feedback or
reward which we assume is an inner
product between the context and some
optimal
unknown vector w star at plus some noise
and we get some regret which is the
difference between uh what we chose the
a that we chose a t versus the optimal a
and of course if we know all the vectors
w star then then we can act optimally
but we don't know them have to learn
them online and we want to minimize
commoditive regret so over the rounds
and minimize this regret
and so the optimal action is context
dependent but there's no stake so
there's nothing carrying on from round
to round
this is we have these classic explore
exploit trade-offs here and usually the
goal is to get sub-linear regret often
some o of square root of t times all
kinds of constants which depend on the
dimension and action space size and so
and large t is just the number of rounds
or interactions or actions we can take
and
we assume in addition to the classic
online linear bandit that we have
triplets of historic data in the form of
context action reward triplets
now if this historic data is fully
observed and there's a complete match
between the offline and online setting
we can use what's called sometimes
learning from log banded feedback or
just classic observational
study
techniques
and use that to initialize online
bandits but we're looking in a slightly
more challenging set up where the
historic offline data is only partially
observed so let's say the actions we
have in the historic data were taken by
humans and humans perceived differently
from machine or maybe it was just not
fully recorded at the time that often
happens like even google which uses
contextual bandits online
it doesn't always
record all the data that went into the
decision of their own algorithms and
maybe there might be privacy constraints
that we just cannot have access to all
this data because some of it is private
okay so so the model we're thinking
about this as this fault so there's this
environment it generates this vector
that we see of context for example
describing the user
uh there is a policy pi b which
generates an action
there's this vector w a which
corresponds to the action and what we
see is this inner product plus noise and
this vector the red thing is part of the
world
and in general this just goes on and on
and if we had fully observable beta we
just we would have seen all these
triplets x a r
but we assume partially observable data
so part of the x vector part of the
context vector used to make the decision
and used to
get the reward is hidden from us we
don't see this in the historic data we
only see it when we play online
and we'll decompose this vector x into
the observable part xo and the hidden
part xh of dimensions l and d minus l
respect
and we assume the offline data had some
policy pi v of a given x
now if we make note for the assumption
the offline data is almost useless right
maybe all the important information is
in the hidden vector and it has no
correlation with the observed part of
the vector and then there's not much we
can do so we have to assume something
else some extra assumption to make this
useful
and
specifically so we go beyond like the
classic bandit literature and the causal
bandit literature
to kind of this
merging and we first just have this
general bandit result which is bandits
with linear constraints which like has
not been explored before maybe because
there weren't many uses for that but
what we show is that bandits where we
have some linear constraints known about
the rewards we can actually translate
this problem
the problem of using offline data to
approximate linear constraints and i'll
give you kind of a hint of how we do
this in the next few slides
uh so what can we say
let's look at the least squares
estimator for the reward given any
particular action so this is using only
the observable part of the vector so we
know this is the best approximate the
best estimate we have we also know it's
bias because we only regress the rewards
on the observed part of the vector so
this relates to kind of misspecified ols
models like going back to the 50s
so we denote this uh regression by bls
least squares for a given action we have
it for any given action this vector b
and b is learned we can estimate it from
the offline data
and now we define these two correlation
matrices ro and roh which are the
cross the covariance of the observed x's
and the cross covariance of the observed
and the hidden axis
and we can show that in the limit of of
infinite theta and assuming the observed
covariances are invertible
then
this vector blsa has this nice structure
which is like this
rectangular matrix of the identity
matrix ro minus 1 times roh times the
optimal vector w star a which i
remind you we would like to know w star
a ideally
for every a
now
okay so this is just a kind of linear
algebra result basically
uh how can
how can we use this so we have some
observable consequences so for every
action a we have this vector bls
and we have this matrix which we denote
m a which as i said is just this
rectangular matrix with this nice
structure
and if we had known m we could have used
the pseudo inverse of m
and just project our estimate w star a
to this pseudo inverse m times bls
because we know we have to obey these
constraints so we can just repeatedly
project onto this constraint that we we
know it must happen from the offline
data again assuming infinite offline
data
and if we had known this we can reduce
regret from
a kind of o of d times square root a t
to o of d minus l so we reduce the
dimension basically exactly by the
exactly
the dimension of the observed part of x
and we get improved record
the problem with this is of course we
don't know m because m has this nasty
part
from so we we get pls and ro minus one
but we don't have roh okay the the
correlation of the observed and hidden
data is hidden because we don't see the
data right the hidden data so
we would like to use these linear
constraints but we can't because there's
still this hidden component
so here is the part where we must assume
something we must assume that we can
have some way to estimate this hidden
part roh
and we can make all kinds of assumptions
i'll talk about one
uh we have like a more general result
but here's one assumption that during
online operation we can query
the behavioral policy so it's not like
we see the hidden component components
and we don't know exactly the policy but
at every round we can ask the behavior
policy what would you have done here we
don't have to act the same but it
assumes we have kind of access to that
model and you know we as like as usual
in causal assumptions you can argue when
and where are they plausible or not and
i just want to say this similar to junk
and byron burns uh a notion of intuition
from their 2016 people
and we show that if you can do this we
can actually approximate the pseudo
inverse ma
which is in generally difficult because
is not a continuous operator but because
it has a special structure we can do
that
and then we can prove this result which
is a
sublinear regret where we save again
this d minus l so we reduce the the
constant factor here by exactly the
dimension of the observed part of the
hidden plus some extra factor
and this extra factor basically says how
hard is it to estimate the linear
constraints and it's related to how like
how uniform is pi b and how well
conditions are these matrices so all the
kind of funky stuff goes into this
factor and just very roughly we can say
that in the worst case
this bound is meaningless it means
like there's no point in using
the offline data in the best case it we
can get actually improved performance
though still dependent on d
so it really depends on the details of
how much is the hidden part of the of
the context vector important and how
well is it correlated with the observer
so in the good scenario it's it's really
useful in the bad scenario it's
it's still basically useless even though
we can
we assume this uh
sampling from piping
okay so
uh
this is one result
about using offline data and kind of
getting faster convergence right so in
in the good scenario we can get uh use
less interactions to get at the optimal
reward using this offline date
okay so this is for the contextual
bandits
and now i want to talk again briefly
uh about uh a slightly more involved
scenario for enforcement learning
uh but
and this is a paper just uh accepted to
iclear 2022
and now we'll talk about this in a more
complicated scenario and we'll mention
we'll talk about imitation learning if i
were in the room i'd ask like people to
raise their hands if they heard about
imitation learning maybe like
could someone tell me like for a raise
of hand how many people are raising
their hands like roughly i have heard
about imitation learning
about 15
15 out of i don't know how many people
are in the room
uh i'm so bad at estimating so maybe
that was about a fifth of the people
okay so most people haven't heard
okay
so invitation learning is this idea
in refreshingly which is really
straightforward it says reflection link
is about like optimizing the reward and
so on but if we have someone
demonstrating to us how to do something
just learn to imitate them so just learn
what action would they do at any given
instant no reward there's no reward in
play and this basically reduces to a
supervised learning problem so you just
learn
when this is the state do this action
and then if you manage to solve this
problem
if nothing changes and everything is all
right then you can do as well as the
demonstrator as well as the person
you're imitating
okay and this is actually widely used
especially in tough reinforcement
learning problems
uh
so for example a deep
deep mind had the starcraft
model alpha star and they used just
imitation learning from human players to
initiate it and even that already broke
the state of the art they they then
built like reinforcement learning on top
of that
to to get even better than that
okay so
basically it's kind of reducing it to
supervised learning but there's a lot of
work on that in in recent years in the
rl community how to do imitation
learning better
i won't get into that specifically and
again we're kind of challenging them all
we're saying okay but uh
what if we have partial observability
again if we're thinking about let's say
a model learning from human drivers like
learning how to drive using human
drivers the human perceives things that
the machine does not
and we have to account for that and
moreover maybe the data was collected in
some different environments
uh for example if we're looking at
recommendation systems maybe you know
the product changes all the time what's
available changes customers change so
the again we're learning from this
offline data from an expert but it was
in a different situation
and again privacy constraints might also
get like
be something that we have to deal with
so let's see how much time do i have
15 minutes
okay i'm good
a bit less
a bit less okay uh
stop me when you need
so
again so we move for bandits where you
have like an x at every time and that's
all the context and just the action
interacts simply you would have a more
involved situation so we have a classic
mdp markup decision process we have a
state and an action
and and oh wait there's a like a here is
action space not safe space i'm sorry
this is just a type of mistake and we
also have a context space so maybe this
will be easier for people in this crowd
so we assume a state and there's an
action
and then we get the reward which again
we might ignore in imitation learning
and then the action also gets us to the
next state which is the function of the
previous state and the action and so and
so on but in addition there's this x
we can think about it as a categorical
variable which says okay but everything
might change based on context right so
driving in the snow is not the same as
driving in the desert
uh and or like recommendation system in
2019 is not the same as 2020 because
many things change
okay so this is the the model we'll
assume and we'll look into cases where
x is not necessarily observable and also
the distributions on x might change
okay so we assume we don't see the
expert's reward that is usually the case
in limitation learning we're just trying
to learn their actions
and we assume they have some optimal
policy pi star which is a function of
both the state and the context
but we don't see the columns
we don't know the context
the use we only see their states and
actions okay so this is one way to model
this partial observability
situation
and further we might have different
distributions over x between the expert
situation and the online situation so he
is expert in osama so it's a form of
coverage
and there's a standard reinforcement
thing there value
and the optimal palace policy will be
the one that maximizes value
and we'll have like the set of
maximizing uh policies uh the optimal
policies that we would like to to enact
but we
can't always do that
so
we have the expert policy pi star so
that generates the trajectory we see
like the driver driving and so on
however
we don't get to see x okay so we just
see these kind of state action state
action like what happened over time
okay
these kind of histories
and they have a probability in the
offline data in the data we get from the
expert and what's written here is just
like
standard probability theory nothing
special just decomposing the
distribution but note that this is a
mixture with some a probability over the
context which again we in we will soon
assume might change and we don't see
this x okay so we have this mixture of
things but we don't know the mixing
coefficients and they might change
okay
but this does generate this distribution
over the state actions
and this is what this is kind of the
information we have we know the traces
the state action traces and we have the
environment like we're acting in
that our agent is in it has their own
traces and the expert has
their traces and they might
might or might not match
and what we define is this ambiguity set
which is the set of all policies so this
is it over policies all policies which
generate the same state action
distributions and again these are our
observables so this is what we can do
and we cannot basically
differentiate between policies
in this set we cannot
if any policy in the set if it induces
the same state action distribution as
the expert policy that's the best we can
know
and what we can show is that any policy
in this ambiguity set is a can be an
optimal policy and we can't rule them
out using state action and frequency
distributions but some might be
sub-optimal so like this is the best we
can do but it's not great because some
of these policies might not be the
optimal policies and there's no way we
can know this even if there's no
coverage
okay so
this is first result which says this
problem is
a bit hard we're not seeing the context
and this makes our life
more difficult
or it might make our life more difficult
we have an algorithm for this situation
which kind of prove we can prove is is
not terrible and proves it's not the
we can do better than the worst but we
can't prove much more about this i i
won't
talk about this
we then say okay let's make this a bit
harder we not only don't see the expert
context but we assume coverage okay so
the expert works under some distribution
over the context we work under a
different distribution we assume they
overlap that there's kind of common
support
and
what we show is that
if
the transition probability is
independent of the context
then the worst case policy cannot be
ruled out so this is this might seem
counterintuitive but it says if if the
contacts don't affect the state
transitions that means basically we have
no clue what's going on because the
state transitions are our only view on
the policy so if they're independent of
the policy and then then we're in
complete dark and we have kind of
nothing that we can do so that might be
that's actually the worst case
on the other hand we have kind of the
best case which says
if the rewards are free of the policy
of the context sorry then basically we
can we can we can do well
and this basically says there's no
confounding if the context doesn't
affect rewards
uh
then
then we're in a good situation
so
uh
there's this kind of
spectrum of options okay
if the reward has nothing to do with the
context
uh then imitation is actually it even
confounded imitation is possible imagine
this kind of maze and imagine we've seen
people acting on the way way
maze without seeing the walls it seems
and let's say in
the expert used one wall setting and
we're in a different setting of walls
but if the goal is just to get to the
left side we can still learn from the
expert that just moving left is good
even if we don't see the details of the
walls and
surprisingly that's kind of helpful
as we said that's like one side of the
equation the other is if the transitions
have nothing to do with the context so
we have this example which says like
there's complete impossibility of
imitating successfully i mean we can
imitate but it will be catastrophic
and there's all the middle okay where
the reward and the transition are both a
context dependence to some degree and we
have a kind of a sensitivity analysis
for this
and that means in those cases imitation
is possible but biased and might be even
highly biased depending on the details
okay
so
imitation so we kind of map the spectrum
of imitation along kind of
when we don't see the context now let's
assume we can actually we get the reward
we're not just trying to imitate but
we're acting in the world and we have
this offline data as an aid
which is more similar to what we did in
the bandit now we have this offline data
we're not trying to purely imitate it we
can act in the world we don't have to
use this offline data but we want to use
it to get better
and what we might want to try is just to
regularize so what we see here is on the
left side the left side is just
maximizing reward we can do that we're
playing online we don't have to use the
offending and this the right term is a
regularization term where df is some
f divergence whatever total variation
this distance or whatever between the
traces that we see in our policy versus
the traces that the experts are saying
okay we know the expert acted optimally
so let's try to to mimic them
we can show this as biased and we can't
even calculate this because we don't
know that the expert distribution over
the context
but we we kind of developed a slightly
more involved optimization problem which
i uh regretfully will not go into the
details which we show is actually
unbiased uh and it has this kind of gan
flavor where we use
it's not again but where we learn kind
of to generate the trajectories and then
we have that's the g and then we have
this kind of
that's a generator and this is a
discriminatory thing okay they need to
be similar but we we're we're not
sensitive to this and we can show that
we will actually converge uh to uh we
this can be solved and this is not
biased we will get to the optimal policy
eventually
and we have kind of two algorithms for
this one which is provably convergent
but it's kind of slow and impractical
one which is gradient based it's a
non-convex objective so you can't prove
anything that actually works
so i won't again i'll skip the algorithm
i'll just describe like one experiment
we did so here we have this we have
weaker theoretical guarantees we don't
have like an impossibility or possible
impossibility results we haven't proven
that we converge faster but we will see
that we do
in practice
we would like to prove more but we
haven't done that yet and i'll show one
experiment using something called the
assistive gym environment from erickson
at all where it's basically a robot
trying to take care of someone feeding
them dressing and bathing them helping
them drink and stuff etc
the state is like the robot and person
state that's a state and the context is
the person's weight height and gender
and disability and their own preferences
on how they'd like to be helped
and the action statement is the joint
forces for the robot and the reward is
success in the task plus these user
friends preferences now we don't have an
expert here we trained an expert on some
density work so we basically built this
dense reward function based on like
understanding the task that helps the
expert learn much better and but then
our model learns using the sparse
original reward which is much more
challenging
and we change the context like all these
weights heights and so on with just some
probability beta
and what we see this is an example of
what the agent learned what we see here
is
that the dashed lines are without our
like kind of this algorithm we developed
uh
which tries to use the offline data
and
the solid lines are using it so we see
we we a better performance over time
though it does not match the expert the
dashline rl is just using rl with no
prior date
and we have this kind of for various
tasks and general we see that our cts
method corrective trajectory sampling
it does perform better
uh just this is how it looks like with
like a large value of beta so a large
degree of coverage if on the left it it
basically fails it doesn't manage to
help address this person which is
different like again different in in in
their characteristics compared to the
offline data
and with sample correction it manages so
it gets
and it managed to learn the uh the
offline data helped it
learn how to do this task correct
so
uh
just to summarize and i'm sorry i didn't
go into all the details of the
algorithms i'm happy to talk about them
offline there's a lot of kind of cool
math stuff going on there which i i
haven't gone into
offline data might make online learning
more efficient that i mean that's pretty
obvious but often it often does not
match online data there's like a lot
there's a lot of discrepancies
discrepancies that we have to think
about if we're actually trying to do
this in the real world
and we're kind of mapping some of the
failure modes and necessary conditions
for success
looked at partial observability and
distribution shifts specifically
in linear bandits we saw that offline
data plus the ability to sample from the
offline policy sometimes allows us to
accelerate online learning depending on
kind of how uh nice uh the the partial
observability is but it it doesn't have
to be super nice just it doesn't have to
be super nasty
and in imitation learning so we're
trying to learn to act like an expert
but things change the context change
the answer is it depends on the details
of how
the context affects
the the problem and we map this kind of
spectrum of like possibility and
impossibility and then we said okay if
we have expert data and we're actually
working online with the reward we're not
just trying to imitate the expert we're
trying to learn on our own but we have
this expert in the background trying to
help us
we have an algorithm empirically
accelerate
it has accelerated convergence and we
can prove that it doesn't harm but we
haven't yet proved that the accelerated
convergence is provably accelerated we
only showed it in like a couple of
extremes i showed you just one example
um
okay i just want to thank the people who
did its work a guide to and and most of
all guy ted holt so these two papers are
part of his phd he's now finishing his
phd thesis and he's a great student
and
i i i'm sure we'll all hear more of him
in the future
and that's it thank you very much for
your time
and happy to take any questions or start
with the discussion
thank you very much marie um so we'll
start with the discussion and have all
the questions just to everyone
um so frederick yes so if you could
go with a chair here in front now we're
having an experiment